okay what's your name Lottie Tasha Lucy
JoJo
Danica who cheats more men or women I'm
gonna say men just because I've heard
more about it women maybe because
they're talks here I feel like it's more
men that get caught but women kind of
get away with it women women it's about
50 50. oh man men of trash
then yes but they're driven by men it's
man's fault you can't make this stuff
man
so like and I obviously turned him down
but yeah someone on this Factory in my
Bayer tried to cheat with a friend I was
with so you know so what if I told you
that one in three men under 30 have are
sexless in the past year
yeah it's harder for guys to get sick
tall guys yeah
what percent of guys do you think are
over six foot
I have to say 20 yeah I've been I'm
quite two anyway that's why I've gone
for six or five only fifteen percent of
men are over six foot the lucky one
maybe yeah so when you think about it
it's a really small percentage of guys
that we want because I'm tall I have to
be picky that's the difference did you
know that one in three men under 30 are
either virgins or haven't had sex in the
past year go through they're Liars yeah
they're Liars you're a liar so what are
your requirements for a guy if you were
to data guy oh you've got to be funny
like unsupportive supportive what about
physical requirement oh I'm not that
fast like if you've got like a good
heart good person like so a 300 300
pounds you're down okay 300 pounds maybe
not I would go for someone that's like a
four out of ten what about money how
much money does he have to have money
like enough to like not be like every
time I'm paying for everything but like
no that that's not an issue like like
we're saying we've earn money okay so if
he's living on his mom's couch you're
down well he's a scrub
an artist and he made twenty thousand
dollars or pounds a year are you cool
with that for Life he's never gonna make
more if he
if he right then and if that's compared
to a man who's on 100K and he's treating
me like then yeah 20K it's more loyal
men or women
women men for sure women men I think
women or women are more secretive they
know what they're doing Hans no I think
no women are more
I think men wait more loyal personally I
would never do I would never do anything
no I would never do that no it was Chris
Brown
no women are definitely more no yeah I
agree women
they just said you'd fly out to see
Chris Brown yeah I've had the
conversation the conversation's been
hard it's Chris Brown yeah did you know
one in three men under 30 are either
virgins or haven't had sex in the past
year not mine yeah
isn't that crazy I would believe it I
mean no I get that I'm a man under that
and I've I have had sex in the last year
come on guy go on go on buy that logic
wouldn't you think that women would
cheat more because I don't think one in
three women are virgins guys pay for
what they want which is the best but
they don't they're not because they're
virgins or they haven't had sex they're
not doing it so do you think that men's
cheating isn't as bad as women's
cheating because if a woman cheats she's
looking for a new relationship or a man
he's just trying to it's both like torn
it was a tournamental again it damages
both like the other partners it's all
about self-control one in three men
under 30 are either virgins or haven't
had sex in the past year it's a very
small percentage so I'll give you an
example on dating apps women only swipe
right five percent of the time where men
swipe right fifty percent of the time so
women are much pickier than men
I can believe that yeah yeah so it's a
small percentage of men that are
cheating that's why like why do you
think women hate men because we're the
same ones that is true but I need to
find those men then clearly because I
mean like look at there's a guy that's
making 35 000 pounds kind of a bomb you
know doesn't really make a lot of money
lives with his mom but he'd be faithful
stand I'm son no no no yeah that's the
thing like kind of everything right we
want Chris Brown's why is the public
perception that men are dogs men are
dogs like they actually are like they
lie I mean we lie but I feel like they
just they're bad lies you know what I'm
saying who do you think lies more men or
women can I say both I might actually
have to say women women maybe do lie
more so why do other stuff why do you
think the public perception is that men
are dogs liars and cheats if we both
well I guess I agree with you I mean
that's just what's put out there like
every like I feel like girls like are
always like men are trash like men are
cheats when they're lies like but maybe
sometimes it's women like why do you
think it's hard for women to look in the
mirror and say that because women are
delusional sometimes we don't want to
know we don't want to admit that we're
wrong we'll never we'll never admit
we're wrong ever do you think women get
caught cheating if they're smart about
you who gets away with cheating more men
or women women men women 100 women get
away with cheating more 100 do you think
one in three women are either virgins or
haven't had sex in the last year one in
three are we are like are we counting
like with themselves or are we counting
like yeah other people yes I would
believe it I believe one in three oh
come on you know live who do you what
girl do you know that's a virgin I don't
know anyone
so then don't you think that women cheat
more than men I think Menchie more than
women but I feel like women women have
more of a reason to just because I feel
like it's more complicated with women
you guys like tall men over six foot
first son of man do you think are over
six foot maybe over 40 no only 15
percent of men are over six foot oh wow
do you think one in three women under 30
haven't had sex in the past
and buy that logic don't women sleep
around more than men aren't they less
loyal I think they do I think they do
especially like London and things like
that personally my experience I don't
sleep around but I don't know what other
girls get up to yeah who gets caught
more men or women men for sure oh yeah
we're good at lying who gets away with
cheating more men or women women don't
get caught we're smarter about it have
any of you been cheated on no no no no
wow never no you have like so how did
you find out he cheated having another
girlfriend and then I found out you had
another girlfriend did you leave when
you found out no how how long did you
stay after you found out six months
maybe six months then I realized on
Valentine's Day when he's spending half
the day with me and the half day with
her it's not really good is it but I was
young I was 17. you're a seven so that
is very young right now never but back
then oh stupid have you ever been
cheated on probably yeah I'd say yeah
that you found out about uh I saw some
messages but I don't know if that's
classes cheating or not I mean isn't she
yeah yeah probably yeah I see yeah did
you stay after you found out he cheated
yes but I was like I was like I was like
18 17 so you've got to let me off for
that like I didn't know have you ever
been cheated on uh no no never never
have you ever looked through a guy's
phone to see okay it's okay
[Laughter]
but you never found anything that's good
no no yeah where are you from by the way
we land so in Finland do you guys have
more like traditional gender roles or is
it more modern would you say uh it's
like traditional yeah it's turning more
into modern but it the traditional is
still up there do you like that I think
that the Finland is a super old school
country and it would lie I would like
that they would take some like notes on
the other countries like in UK do you
prefer it when a guy pays or do you
prefer to split it 50 50. it doesn't
matter for me I can split my pill you
make your own money I make my own money
yeah I can pay my flowers have you ever
been cheated on
um I wouldn't say cheated but
disappointed
just you know some sneaky sneaky so
after you found the sneaky did you stay
or did you leave oh I'm gone with the
win okay have you okay okay have you
guys ever been cheated on yeah it's on
yes yeah okay so for the two that have
been cheated on after you found out he
was cheating did you stay yeah yeah yeah
I was 16 it was like how how long after
he cheated did you end up leaving
probably about like four or five months
yeah it was about it was a good couple
of months I think the phrase is true
that women plan the breakup six months
before yeah
100 yeah and the words of Chris Brown
are these loyal no they ain't loyal
no that's not loyal don't trust them no
losers ain't loyal but never I am I I
was an ex I'm not her anymore I'm
definitely an ex-husband but I am loyal
so what age did you start being a 25 24
but I started at about 17. in the words
of Chris Brown are these loyal no
[Music]
yes yes
we are but I don't know about the other
no they're never loyal never alone in
the words of Chris Brown are these loyal
they ain't loyal no no
absolutely blood clot not absolutely not
nope
[Music]
no way no some of them as many of you
know I was just banned on Tick Tock and
we are demonetized on a daily basis on
this platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible